حققت اللاعب السعوديه رنيم الشريف واللاعب
سعود الدوسري
الميداليتين البرونزيتين في اولى
مشاركتهما الدوليه وذلك ضمن مسابقه كاس
العالم المفتوحه للكيك بوكسينغ التي
اختتمت يوم امس في اسطنبول بمشاركته اكثر
من ثلاثه الاف لاعب من 47 دوله وتعد بطوله
انديه العالم المفتوحه من البطولات
الرسميه التي تدرج ضمن تقويم اتحاد
الواكوا السنوي للبطولات
ومعنا من جده لعبت الكيك بوكسينج رنيم
الشريف رنيم مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابع
من الرياض
مبروك سرتي عالميه برونزيه في كاس العالم
ما شاء الله وكيف كانت المشاركه كلمين
عنها اكثر الاجواء اللي كانت فيها الحماس
والله صراحه المشاركه مره كانت حلوه وكانت
اول مره نمثله السعوديه باسمه الاتحاد
السعودي للكيك بوكسينج
وحققنا ميداليتين طبعا لعبنا مع اكثر من
3500 شخص ما كان سهل الموضوع لكن الحمد
لله رجع ما كان سهل وشكله تصعب مباراه
لعبتيها في البطوله يعني المستويات اللي
كانت موجوده الناس من زمان مدربين ناس
كثير موجودين احنا لسه دوبنا جداد في
اللعبه بدانا في المنتخب اول مره نطلع
فالحمد لله اني حققنا يعني ميداليه
الاتحاد تقريبا سته شهور
تقريبا 6 شهور لكن ساهم معانا
الحمد لله يعني سته شهور حققته بذيليتين
انت
ممتاز كلميني عن الاستعداد اللي كان قبل
هذه البطوله كيف استعديتو
لحد اخذنا معسكر قبل البطوله في الرياض
كان وجابوا لنا اربعه مدربين للكيك
بوكسينج وكانت يعني صراحه تجربه جميله
وساهموا معانا ودعمونا ماديا ومعنويا
للاتحاد ما قصروا يعني الحمد لله وطبعا
نحب نشكر الاستاذ احمد الطويالي
والاستاذ عبد الملك المزيد ما قصروا معانا
فهذا كله الحمد لله وش الفرق يا رنين بين
انك اليوم لاعبه تحت هذا الاتحاد
وفتره ما قبل هذا الاتحاد لما كنت لاعبه
فرديه يعني
زمان ما كان عندي له دعم لا من اتحاد ولا
من احد ما كان عندنا
مدربين لكن الاتحاد هذه مره كان يدور
ورانا كلمونا بالاسم والدونا بطولات كانوا
معانا في كل حاجه يعني
[موسيقى]
افضل يعني بالنسبه لك يعني
ما دعم الاتحاد يعني نقدر نوصل بطولات وان
شاء الله في بطولات جايه كمان اكثر معاهم
وبعده هذا الميداليه العالميه البرونزيه
وايش عندكم مشاركات
ان شاء الله الشهر الجاي حيطلع بطوله
الاردن برضو حتكون طول عالميه عالميه
بيكون في السعوديه في بطوله كيك بوكس برضه
ان شاء الله والجايات اكثر طبعا ان شاء
الله يعني
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يا رب الجاي احسن
ان شاء الله باذن الله شكرا جزيلا لك من
جده لعبه الكيك بوكسينج رنيم الشريف